Hi everyone, hope you're all well. So
last year I visited Japan for the first
time and finally just now I've got round
to editing the videos. I flew into Tokyo
and whilst I was there I did some
traveling and sightseeing but most of
all I managed to get in some training. I
visited Aama and although I have some
footage from the Aiki Shrine and Dojo
which I can share, unfortunately I'm not
permitted to upload any of the training
footage. The same applies for a couple
of other seminars that I attended whilst
I was there.
I was however allowed to film during my
attendance at a shoot Iikido seminar
with Sakurai Sensei. This is a very
unique style of iikido which includes
sparring. I'll be sharing some footage
from that seminar soon, so keep an eye
out for future videos. Until then, take
care.